it seems like almost on a daily basis
people in the bitcoin community talk
about the failure of states central
banks or other types of really important
organizations but we usually don't
actually see it occur in real time
unfortunately in lebanon right now
that's exactly what we're watching
though today the country of lebanon has
announced that they are officially
bankrupt what exactly does that mean if
we go ahead and we take a look at what
is going on in the country you can see
that lebanon is in the third year of a
financial implosion according to reuters
that has been caused by decades of
corruption and bad policies the currency
has crashed in value by more than 90
percent and banks have locked most of
the savers out of the hard currency
accounts the world bank estimates that
that country's economy has actually
contracted by nearly 60 percent in the
last two and a half years or so and so
when we start to look at this this is
really bad for the people on the ground
anyone living in lebanon not only is
watching the economy contract not only
watching their local currency fall off a
cliff but now the state and the central
bank are coming out and saying we're
bankrupt we literally can't get out of
this situation and so if we take a look
at this tweet from economist steve hanke
what we can see is that since january
31st of this year the local bank's
foreign currency reserves have fallen by
837 million dollars he attributes this
to the fact that they are foolishly
selling us dollar reserves to try to
prop up the lebanese pound and
ultimately what we are watching is the
implosion of an economy a central bank
and ultimately the state if we go ahead
and we take a look at the deputy prime
minister's thoughts what we can see is
that it's not so hot he says that the
losses will be distributed to the state
the central bank the banks and
depositors and that there is no specific
percentage unfortunately the state is
bankrupt as is the bank of lebanon and
we want to come out with a result and
the loss occurred due to policies for
decades and if we did nothing the loss
would be much greater he then goes on
and states that he's in the midst of
negotiations with the imf and are in
daily contact with that organization for
the first time this large mission has
come and we've made great progress with
the imf negotiations now regardless of
what comes out of those negotiations
between the country of lebanon and the
imf ultimately the everyday citizen is
in trouble they're getting pushed into a
dire situation
their country is falling apart the
economy is failing the local currency is
failing they simply want to be able to
protect themselves and this is where
people step in and they say bitcoin was
built for this bitcoin quite literally
fixes this if you are able to get access
to the internet you can get access to a
hard currency digital sound money that
no one can inflate away
you literally get
digital property rights and it allows
you to protect your wealth your savings
your purchasing power and it allows you
to be immune to the undisciplined
monetary and fiscal policies both in
america but also abroad eventually the
people lebanon slowly but surely are
starting to be orange pill they're
understanding the value of bitcoin and
my guess is that for generations to come
those people will tell their children
and their grandchildren
be wary of undisciplined monetary fiscal
policy because they've lived through the
consequences and hopefully the rest of
the world is paying attention so that
the rest of the citizens globally don't
have to experience the same pain that
the average lebanese citizen is going
through today hey you did you like this
video great we make five of them a day
and post them here on this channel make
sure you subscribe like the video and
see you next time